night Lautrec looks out for himself if
we are to judge him then we should count
our own sins first you who invades for
Humanity you who kills simply because
something is in your way or because they
have something important to you
helm of law Trek the embraced
representing the goddess Venus love
during his solitude he forsook
everything for he believed in the
goddess is love for him ring of favor
and protection granted by FINA known in
legend to possess fateful beauty the
ring breaks if ever removed armor of law
trek the embraced representing the
goddess Venus loved the goddesses arms
wrap around it as if to embrace the
wearer the goddess Athena seems more
sinister than you would expect from a
goddess of love she appears to a man who
is forsaken everything who will commit
atrocities to serve her ring of
protection breaks if you abandon her the
armour wraps its arms around you
clinging to the wearer is it a reminder
of her love or to remind you that you
are hers we know her love is faithful if
you're hers you're well and truly a part
of her design whatever goal she has are
yours as well so did FINA really love
him deeply and personally it's possible
interactions between the gods and the
humans are quite common it's also
possible that the man is simply within a
religious delusion we first encounter
Knight Lautrec in a cell within the
undead church why a church has a cell is
a story in and of itself as is the story
of how law Trek came to be trapped there
it could have something to do with the
fire cube assault down below or perhaps
Oswald the partner maybe both for if
anyone is drenched in sin it's Lord
wreck and his desire for more humanity
is clear even patches speaks of it it
comes as no surprise then that Lautrec's
sets his sight on a harmless fire keeper
via keepers are corporal manifestations
of the bonfires they keep their souls
are a draw for Humanity offered to the
bonfire and as such their souls are
gnawed by infinite humanity it's clear
that this isn't a fate that the fire
keeper enjoys since she expresses that
she wishes for the curse of the undead
to be
lifted so that she may die as a human
her tongue was cut out so she could not
complain and her blood-stained skirt
implies that she was maimed so that she
may not escape yet despite this she
expresses a desire to fulfill her fate
as a fire keeper to a man who desires
humanity whether for his goddess saw for
himself a fire keeper soul is quite a
prize laura escapes with the fire keeper
soul whether he desires it for himself
as a trophy or for his goddess is
unclear yet you and many other parallel
undead track him down and invade his
world
here we got a rush to sport
let's get it over with
[Music]
[Music]
this is the end of night Lautrec
whatever his designs were whatever the
goddess wanted it died with him so is it
worth restoring the fire keeper or will
you give in to the same temptations as
law Trek who wants to go hollow after
all
[Music]
you